[Music]
all right
so for those who are wondering why i'm
laughing i forgot to press the record
button and i'm glad that we were able to
catch it roloff so nice to see you again
it's been quite a few years
and i'm so thrilled that you've
been able to
make time and that both of us have been
able to make time to have this
conversation so thanks for being here
thank you for hosting tim and
look forward to the conversation
so i thought we would start with a
question that i asked before
we pressed record on our backup and not
the primary and that is how do you
pronounce your full name properly if you
were in your homeland
my parents would call me ruloff
roloff
pretty close
i'm not going to pass for enough for a
connor but
your pronunciation is excellent i'll
respond to that
i have heard a number of fireside songs
in uh is it in afrikaans i suppose it
would be vidcon's having spent some time
in in south africa in the last year but
we're not going to spend a lot of time
on that i want to though spend time on
note taking and also
different visual cues that you've used
at different points in your life and so
here goes the first question the first
question is
i have
and you can't
believe everything that you read on the
internet but something in front of me
that says you used to have
10 to the ninth power written in the
corner of your notepad i guess every
week when you started at sequoia is that
accurate and if so could you explain why
that's the case
that is accurate
when i joined sequoia
it was clear that if if i wanted to make
it as a partner
you needed to produce meaningful gains
and i'd set myself the goal of producing
a billion dollars in gains for the
partnership because that would mean that
i had made it at some level and so 10 to
the nine which is a billion was my short
hand of reminding myself what i was
striving for
now what was the notepad used for
otherwise and was this on the top of
every page or
something you saw
on a weekly basis i'm wondering on these
the frequency with which you saw this
and also what the notepad was used for
otherwise
this notepad was used generally for note
taking but it was really on mondays in
particular when we had a partner meeting
where we would review all the decisions
for a particular day
and that would be the notepad where i'd
make notes about the companies that were
listening to my own
views on companies what did i worry
about what did i think was interesting
and so
that was the most important day at some
level you know we referred to it as the
olympic finals at sukhoi it was the
monday partner meeting and the
importance of getting those decisions
right and so that was the day where i
needed to remember very acutely what was
i striving for
so i done this when i was younger too i
don't know if you'd heard this i had and
we're going to get to that okay let me
ask you before we before we flash back
and do the wavy austin powers flashback
to childhood which i will do in a minute
with the 10 to the ninth did you have in
your mind a particular time frame for
that or was it just a reminder of the
magnitude of the goal before you if you
wanted to move the needle
i didn't really have a time dimension at
the time you know things have changed a
lot in the venture business
technology has infused so much more of
the world i mean i i keep reminding
myself when i was at paypal in 2000
there were about 200 million people on
the planet that had internet 200 million
that's wild and the vast majority of
them were on dial-up
right so by the time i joined sukhoi in
2003 we we didn't even have broadband
reaching 50 of the us population yet so
the numbers were still much smaller and
technology didn't have the scale that it
does have today and so i just thought
eventually get to a billion now honestly
i feel like it's 10 to the 10 that you
need to strive for
because you know technology just infused
so much of what we do
so let's do as promised the
the rewind to
childhood
and i'll let you take this ball and run
with it wherever you want to go but
i did read a bit about your high school
system of having your goals visible to
you
while you were studying at least that's
that's based on a bit of reading i think
this is actually from it should be
accurate because it's from skycap.com or
the articles thereof so could you please
elaborate
on what you did
back during that era of your life
i thought i needed
there's a concept in psychology called
the ulysses pact which is this idea that
you know in the both of ulysses he
wanted to hear the sirens so he had all
these soldiers all his sailors wax up
their ears time to a mast and that way
they could sell past and he could hear
the sirens
and they wouldn't succumb to them and so
in psychology the ulysses pact is this
idea that you make a
pact with your future self knowing that
your future self is going to be weak and
so my technique for doing this not
having read about psychology yet was to
put notes in front of my desk on the
door leaving my room and candidly all
over my room reminding me what i was
aiming for
and in high school it was to be the top
10 in my state at the end of high school
at college it was to be number one and i
would just put all these reminders of
what my goals were so if i was tempted
to get up to go make a cup of tea or
watch television or take a break
i would just see what i'd written to
myself and i'm reminded of what i need
to do if i want to achieve what i want
to achieve in life
do you still use reminders
like that of of of any type or do you
feel like you've hit a certain
escape velocity where that's no longer
necessary
i still use some of those i mean when i
was at sequoia you know as you pointed
out earlier i had the 10 to the nine
i try to keep track of how i spend my
time
when i was in college i would literally
write down the time that i started
studying down to the minute and then i
write down the time that i got up so
that i would have an accurate tally at
the end of the day of exactly how much
time i actually spent studying instead
of just thinking that i was studying and
just loafing around the house doing
nothing and so
i use evernote to do that i organize key
things that i want to accomplish
for sequoia and for each of the
companies that i work with um so i
always have this running list of what
are the key things you need to focus on
the most important the three most
important things you need to accomplish
for a given company
over the next say six months as a
reminder of the most important things
i want to jump next to a headline
and this is i believe
a headline in a local newspaper when you
graduated from high school you can
correct me if i get any of these details
wrong
and it was and again i'm not going to
pronounce this correctly because
i will play it safe and use my my long
island accent so botha's grandson is
number one
i believe was the headline
could you
use that as a segue into explaining who
your grandfather was but also i'd love
to just know
how that headline landed for you
and what it felt like
so my grandfather was
the equivalent of the foreign secretary
for south africa and i think he served
for close to 20 years in that capacity
he was ambassador for south africa to
germany to denmark and to the united
nations
in his time he'd met reagan and thatcher
and kissinger and these are the sort of
people he interacted with and he was a
part of the national party of a
government that ran south africa until
the first democratic elections in 1994.
my grandfather was an agent for change
even though he worked in the party that
was the ruling party that had enforced
apartheid he wanted a galvanized change
from within so he was part of the the
group that announced the unbanning of
the anc in 1990 and he actually served
in nelson mandela's first democratically
elected government from 1994 till 1996
when he retired
so he was a very well known very
prominent politician you know by some
measure when i was a child growing up he
was probably the second most powerful
politician in the country
i was named after him
it was literally you know the convention
in in the afrikaan culture was that the
firstborn son gets the father's father's
name and so that's why i was named after
him
but because he was so well known it
meant that i also lived in a shadow and
i was often referred to as so-and-so's
grandson you know papueta's grandson and
so the headline referred to him and i
was proud of my achievement and i was
proud of my grandfather but at some
level i also wanted to be myself and to
prove myself and not be
always referred to as you know in
reference to somebody else
so we may come back to that
but
you seem like someone who has
repeatedly
not taken the path of least resistance
which i mean is a compliment for sure
let's talk about
actuarial science now i must say one of
the funniest things that has happened to
me in the last few days is in the
process of doing research for this you
may know this but if you throw your name
into google
the first thing that pops up
is role of both the south african
actuary which i love i just think that's
fantastic so could you please explain
why you chose actuarial science
as your degree and
also by way of doing that just explain
what actuarial science is so i finished
high school in 1990 uh the year the nc
was unbanned and honestly
at the time it was unclear whether south
africa would have a peaceful transition
to democracy
if you'd looked at the history of most
other african nations that had gone
through this kind of a change from sort
of a quote-unquote colonial past
the picture wasn't pretty
and so when i chose what to study part
of the dimension was would it give me an
ability to work and live abroad
and actuarial science was something
where after you got your undergraduate
degree you'd study professional exams
and become a british qualified actuary
so technically i became a uk actuary
which meant that i could work in the uk
in canada in australia and a couple of
other commonwealth countries and so the
portability of my qualification was a
really important decision point
the other one was the most difficult
degree to get into
you could get a bursary to study for it
my family couldn't afford college so
i got an insurance company to actually
pay for my tuition
and it was challenging so what actuaries
do by the way is they run insurance
companies pension funds
so whether that's life insurance or
general insurance and are involved
within investment management for those
companies as well
so
think think of it as a financial
engineering degree so technically i
majored in actual science economics and
statistics so there's a heavy emphasis
on mathematical statistics as part of
the degree
so in addition to the math and
i i don't have the full context here in
front of me but does uct stand for the
university of cape town am i getting
that right i may not be i'm not all
right
i thought the university that most
people know of right
well right exactly so i wanted to just
confirm that
and build off of what you said to add
this is a i guess an indirect quote the
way that i'm going to read it but
professor robert dorrington
at uct
has said quote actuaries are trained to
think 30 years into the future and
accountants are trained to think a year
in arrears
do you feel like your
training or maybe the attributes that
led to you choosing actuarial science
supported well to
entrepreneurship and venture capital or
do you think that's too too much of a
reach
i think it did honestly as i said
earlier the actuarial degree
is about financial engineering sort of
the mathematics of finance if you will
and so in a very practical sense when i
was at paypal the techniques i'd learned
were useful in understanding the fraud
problem that was latent at paypal and we
were able to catch our fraud challenges
months before others did and is part of
the reason that paypal survived so you
know a bit of a twist of history that
that training actually was very
specifically helpful in that situation
but this idea of thinking long term
there's a great article or a concept
about the time span of discretion what's
the horizon over which somebody
thinks and plans
and i think part of
what we
try to focus on it's a great part of
what i think has made me a decent
investor is just trying to think much
longer term not just thinking quarter to
quarter or a year out but thinking about
the possibility of what might happen
with companies down the road and we've
had a chance to go read the original
youtube investment memo for example but
you know there were three founders
friends of mine from paypal days when we
invested
i was the fourth person really to join
the company when we invested and
you know there was a way of imagining
what might happen if this actually works
what if it goes right because it's so
easy to worry about all the things that
can go wrong with every company so so i
do think the training held but in the
classic nature nurture debate how much
you know was i pre-wired to think that
way or not i don't know these things
feed on each other
it uh i'm not going to even make an
attempt to separate those i don't think
i can do it in my own life so i won't
even presume to be able to do it for
anybody else
i would love to
ask you and we're going to bounce around
a lot because i don't want to do this
chronologically i wouldn't do that if we
were just having wine over dinner so i'm
just going to follow my interest here
and then perhaps we'll we'll jump back
to
paypal so that the first question i
suppose is somewhat chronological
it under what circumstances would you
recommend
to
a young
would-be entrepreneur that they go into
consulting or would you generally advise
against
that path
i would generally advise against that
as a career choice
i chose to work at mckinsey i don't
regret the decision i made but for me it
was
again an opportunity to work with an
international firm
remember i worked at mckinsey from 96 to
98 so south africa just opened up from
sanctions we'd had sanctions from 1985
to 1994
the country was starved for
international talent and so
you know this international firm shows
up
i could learn from people from all over
the world and they would give me an
opportunity to either study or to work
abroad so that was a lot of the
magnetism for me to join mckinsey at
that time
i think if you're already in the us
go do something a little bit more direct
review my advice the best business
school is actually being in business
going to join a company and actually
experiencing what it's like so if that's
your ambition and this if you want to be
a consultant there's nothing wrong with
that but i think as a way of delaying
difficult decisions about what might
happen your career it's it's a played
safe decision it's not a risk seeking
decision
so i have a number of friends including
a
fantastic meticulous
doctor named peter tia who spent time at
mckinsey and
peter as one example
loves matrices
and specifically he loves two by two
matrices and
i'd love for you
to explain who don valentin
is
and
we're gonna we're gonna explore that a
bit but uh
could you also explain what his 2x2
matrix was
so don valentine is one of the fathers
of
silicon valley one of the fathers of
venture capital
don
grew up in the semiconductor business he
was a national and fair child
semiconductor back in the 1960s and he
started sequoia capital in 1972
and
we should get back to this later but he
made a very important decision calling
it sequoyah capital and not valentine
capital
don had an amazing career as an investor
he
backed apple
when a lot of people were unsure about
backing a barefooted not well-dressed
steve jobs he backed atari he backed ea
he backed
oracle cisco and the list goes on he had
a remarkable track record as an investor
and when i joined sequoia he was
still around still alive he passed away
two years ago
and very early on he pulled me aside and
he said
there's a two by two metrics of people
we get to invest in exceptional not
exceptional
uh easy to get along with not so easy to
get along with
your job to date real life is to figure
out in which of those four quadrants we
normally make money
so i i have not heard this story i don't
know the answer i i could hazard a guess
but why don't why don't you
tell us number one did you figure it out
and what is the answer i think you have
an intuition for it it's you know
exceptional not so easy to give along
with
and the reason it's you know when you
think about the
the founder
prototype or you know personality type
you know most of us encounter challenges
in the world and we just let it go
you know this is difficult this doesn't
work this frustrates me and you just go
ah whatever and you move on to the next
thing founders are these people who
don't take no you know they don't accept
the way the world is they want to change
it they encounter frustration
and they do something about it but going
back to the cisco example right the
founders of cisco were the heads of the
computer departments for computer
science and the business school at
stanford and they were on different
networks so they could send primitive
electronic mail within departments but
not across campus and the two of them
were romantically involved and we're
getting tired of walking across campus
to see each other they wanted to i'm not
kidding you this is the like the first
international story it's great this is
fantastic yeah and so the founding
inspiration for cisco was connecting the
networks of the computer science and
business schools at
at stanford and that's the founding
story right instead of just accepting
the status quo and so there's so many
other companies we're back with this is
the example right jack and and jim
started square because there was a lost
sale i mean these personal frustrations
are just incredibly powerful so when you
think about a person who wants to take
on the world and doesn't just accept it
that tells you a lot
about what the founder is like
right and they're highly likely to push
back on on
anything that i would imagine that they
don't feel is fully aligned with the
change that they want to
leave in the world or
in part to the world
what are some other characteristics
that could be related to the exceptional
not so easy to get along with or they
could be separate
that you have identified within the data
set of
hits from sequoia
where you've made money and by you i
mean sequoia
well first it starts with an authentic
identification with a problem
i think when that that founding
inspiration because if you if you're
trying to start a business for the sake
of starting a business
it's it's so hard
there are so many challenges on the on
the way to building a successful company
if you're doing it for the wrong reasons
you're going to wilt
you you simply won't persevere but if
you're deeply motivated by what you're
doing you'll keep going and you'll
overcome obstacle after obstacle and so
that to me is one of the key starting
conditions is
founder market fit found a problem fit
what you know i love asking a founder
and i meet them like how did you come up
with this idea
like what was the eureka moment where
something snapped and you want to do to
address this problem and what is it
about the current solutions that you
must have evaluated that frustrated you
that you didn't think was good enough
and then the next one is what's your
unique and compelling value proposition
so
having evaluated alternatives and
deciding to build something why do you
think what you're building is so
distinct that it has a chance of
flourishing and becoming a real business
so i can tell you one specific story
there's a founder matra binovitz he and
i met in high school
in south africa in 1987 at a nerd camp
uh it was actually called an academic
vacation school but i mean that's just a
very nice way of saying
and
he's absolutely brilliant he was gold
medalist in a national science olympiad
he came to stanford he studied physics
electrical engineering and in 2002 his
sister had a baby that died within a
week of birth and he was shocked at the
state of prenatal testing
and he went back to stanford and he
learned everything he could about
biology and genetics and started this
company in natera
where i'm still on the board 15 years
later we made a million dollar seed
investment in him in 2006 just an idea
and today they they deliver millions of
tests to help people have healthy
families
but it started with an incredibly
authentic inspiration for him which is
seeing what his sister had to deal with
you know i've never heard
the
elegance of this
phrase you used before the founder
problem fit but
and i am just a a tourist in the startup
world compared to your immersion as an
entrepreneur operator and investor but
if i look back at all of the angel
investments i've made
the founder problem fit is the defining
feature of any of the hits not
product market fit which may also exist
but in terms of
the hierarchy of weighted importance
it's this founder problem fit that's a
fantastic phrase
what else have you learned or did you
learn
rather from don valentin and it could
just be anything that you observed in
him
attribute behavior habit or otherwise
but what are some of the
takeaways
from having spent time with him
incredibly good listener
you think about the
stereotype maybe of an investor who's
fast talking and needs to be heard
don was very comfortable sitting for an
hour and just listening
and absorbing and then he was very
precise with his questions precise with
his notes i remember
receiving a note in my inbox from don
i was confused initially because there
was no to or from so i didn't know who
it was you know who'd written me this
note
so i walked around the office saying you
know who left this for me and people
looked at it and said it's written in
green ink
it's dawn
so donna had exclusive use of green ink
in the office no one else was allowed to
use a green pen he loved the color of
money
but he would take a full page and there
maybe be 10 words on the page
and they just they were just so
incredibly concise and describing the
feedback that he wanted to give about a
company or when he interviewed people i
saw some of his interview notes about
people
you know instead of writing two pages of
notes about the interview
who's just so crisp and on the point and
so his ability to distill things very
concisely is incredible
[Music]
you mentioned earlier
the question of
what happens if this goes right and i'm
paraphrasing but like what does this
look like say five ten years down the
line even more if this goes right
could you speak to
the practice of
pre-mortems and pre-parades if i'm
getting the term
correct
correct
it was actually a technique that i
picked up from larry summers
so for my treasury secretary summers is
on the board with me at square and he
actually joined pretty early he's been
on the board for almost a decade with me
now
and he posed this as a challenge to the
management team at square about
imagine things go incredibly well over
the next three or five years
actually write it down don't just think
about it write down what does that look
like what does success really look like
what does the company look like what
have you achieved
which markets do we operate in which
products have we shipped
then go write a pre mortem
things didn't go the way you wanted to
what does that look like
and so we've taken that concept we
actually use it in our investment memos
so for every investment we contemplate
we write a pre-mortem and a pre-parade
and when we've had strategy offsites for
for ourselves for the square capital
investment team
we did this too we had a pre-mortem it
literally said 20 30 autopsy of sequoia
capital and what went wrong what all the
things are going to cause us to not be a
great firm in the future and the the
value of this exercise is again back to
the insights from don
it really crystallizes first order
issues
because you can spend all your time
scurrying around doing all the busy work
if you're not focused on the things that
will really compound and matter over the
next five to ten years you're missing
the boat and it's the urgent important
trade-off and it's all those things
woven into a very practical exercise
how often would you do the
pre-mortems
at the sequoia
i suppose team off sites
right every two years
every two years i think every year is
too frequent because things things don't
just don't change that often i mean we
may revisit something if there's
something that's really changed
there's a why now why now is one of the
questions we'd love to ask obviously
like why now so you know we made an
off-cycle decision to open up in europe
for example something we hadn't done for
a decade we kept on thinking about
should we open up an office in in europe
should we be on the ground instead we
kept on flying into europe and we made
some great investments we were early
investors in unity and klarna and you
know several other companies
on the continent and at some point we
realized
there's just so much company formation
happening in in europe and especially
after the global financial crisis the
the there's a whole crop of young people
in europe that now aspire to building
companies when that wasn't the case
before so we revisited our assumptions
and changed and that was an off-cycle
decision
let's dig a little bit deeper on the the
pre-mortems specifically as applied to
sequoia so let's just say
you're
at an off site and let's you can pull a
real one to mind
and you're asking yourselves you know
imagine the venture business in 10 years
time
sequoia is gone
what happened
are there any
answers that you can brainstorms that
you can share that prove to be very
valuable in decision making for the firm
because i will say for people who don't
know the venture capital
ecosystem
one
thing of many that has impressed me
forever for as long as i've known about
sequoia is the longevity
of sequoia
are there any examples that you could
give of pre-mortem answers that have
proven very important in decision making
for sure by the way the
long live
you know that the sequoia tree is the
longest live tree in california i do
right and that's the reason that don
chose to name sequoia sequoia it wasn't
an accident he wanted the partnership to
outlive him with a lot of consequent
behavior and actions and he also wanted
us to invest in companies that stand the
test of time which i think we've done
disproportionately so
you know the couple of things from the
offsides you know
i think one of the most important ones
is hubris
you know the downfall of every greek
tragedy
and the extent to which we rest on
yesterday's success and one of my
favorite quotes is
no wreath
wilts as fast as one that's rested on
we cannot rest on the past and it's part
of what motivated me when i joined
square by the way i you know the motto
we have inside our building is you're
only as good as your next investment
and i saw that hunger and determination
from people like mike moritz and doug
leone who clearly made it in life and
yet they were relentless in the pursuit
so very important for us as a team to
think about hubris
we need to make sure that we continue to
meet companies at the earlier stages of
formation
so
when you go back when we made if you
think about the history of sequoia's
investments when we invested in atari or
apple or cisco we were the first
investors they were often single digit
numbers of people around the company
when we first invested we invested in
youtube there were three people linkedin
there were seven people palo alto
networks one founder in our office
incubating him
if we start losing grip of that early
stage of being in touch with
entrepreneurs right at inception that's
very dangerous for us there's this
temptation to then drift downstream and
become a late stage investor and so
that's probably one of the most
important things we talked about in the
offsite is we've got to make sure that
we stay at the fountainhead of company
formation
so let me ask a follow-up related to
that last
point and this may be getting too into
the weeds but i'm curious
early stage investing has become
so
i would say competitive or at least the
field is flooded with players compared
to say 2007
when i first started paying attention to
the startup investing world
it's almost nothing
like it was today in terms of
competition and the number of just sheer
the sheer number of people willing to
write checks in different forms in
different fashions
i would imagine with a
famous firm
with multiple funds as you get to larger
fund sizes
in order to invest at the earliest
stages and have those offers be accepted
without over diluting the founders it
seems like you would have to amass
an army of people to
maybe handle that to have sufficient
capital outflows to make the entire
operation work
how did you guys think about solving for
still investing
at the very early stages as the firm and
the funds grew
so
we don't want to hire an army of people
our investment team candidly is about
unchanged over the last decade
we only have about two dozen or so
investors in our u.s and europe business
because if you want to make good
investment decisions you need to have
small decision making groups
you know committees don't make great
decisions because then you average to
the mean and great investments depend on
outlier instincts
and we are looking for the outlier
founders the founders who dare to build
really exceptional companies not just
investable companies so we've tried to
keep the team small we've also kept our
funds separate so we have a seed fund
that's distinct from a venture fund
that's distinct from our growth fund and
the teams are lined up against each of
those because i think what you point out
is a real risk that if you have
i'm just going to make it up let's just
suppose you have one pool of capital you
have one 10 billion dollar fund making a
500 000 seed investment and something
promising seems you know kind of
irrelevant it's surrounding era and then
the whole team starts chasing what they
think of bigger investments
and so that's one of the dangers that
we've we've guarded again so we have
separate teams focused on different
areas and the key is to look at the
multiples it's not about the input you
know many of these small investments
we've made have turned into very large
gains it's not about about how much you
invest is about the the impact it can
have
in terms of the competition by the way i
actually think it's fantastic that
there's this much competition
because what used to be a cottage
industry in the 1980s and 90s because
that's just it wasn't a big market i'm
not saying that dismissively it was just
it was a smallish industry
the
the industry has had to professionalize
the beneficiary of that ultimately are
the founders like we've had to up our
game
yes we had a talent team when i was
still at paypal sequoia had a talent
team but you know it was one or two
people now we have 15.
and we're just delivering many more
services to
startups to help these companies succeed
to give them an unfair edge and a chance
of outsize success so so i think it's
really in service of founders it's it's
fantastic that the business is like this
it makes it more competitive but it's
all right
yeah i think you guys are going to be
fine
uh i mean it's also
i
think incredibly advantageous to build a
winning streak
and to have the track record that
say a firm such as sequoia has because
you also
have a selection bias with inbound with
respect to very good deals so i suppose
that helps in part with maintaining a
smaller team as opposed to a larger
scouting team that's going out and
canvassing sort of every corner
of the landscape is is that a fair
comment or do you think that's
that's not
is there more to the story that you'd
like to flesh out
i think it's true
we're blessed by having the history we
do so the companies that we backed when
they were private today account for over
25 percent of the total value of the
nasdaq that's wild
over a quarter of the nasdaq were
companies that we backed when they were
private no other venture firm comes
close
right so that is an incredible
achievement and it means that we're a
magnet for other opportunities often
because of sector expertise or
experience so because i'm the board of
unity i might disproportionately get
people who work in vr and ar because
they're developing on the unity
ecosystem and so that gives us access to
this so there is a way in which the
industry success begets success for sure
but it can also be a curse because if
you have a lot of inbound
are you spending enough time thinking
critically about where you want to spend
time where the opportunities for
tomorrow might lie and so there's a
danger there that you you may spend all
your time just taking inbound
opportunities instead of pursuing the
best founders and the best company so
there's a balance there roloff what
books
if if any come to mind as books that you
have
recommended or gifted the most to
other people
but the two different ones there's man's
search for meaning by viktor frankl
which invariably shows up on these lists
of you know 100 books you should read
before you die
which really had a big impact on me and
i've spoken about it at sequoia founder
events i've given it to many people i
just think the book is amazing in terms
of helping clarify
what it is that motivates you and what
drives you
like what is your purpose
because we're not really driven by
monetary rewards or you know pleasure by
itself so that to me is a fantastic book
the other one is an annual series called
america's best science and nature
writing
and it's a collection of about two dozen
articles from american publications
written for a lay audience across a
range of topics you know it could be
what's the latest insights from
physics and
astronomy to what's happening in
genetics what's happening with
anthropology or things like i mean it's
absolutely fascinating
could you give us
and it doesn't have to be short
certainly
but i wouldn't expect you to
redeliver any of your presentations
why has
viktor frankl's book had
such an impact on you
and it is an exceptional book to be
clear but i'd just love to hear
how it resonated with you or impacted
you
i think it reduced
very clearly
the need to think about what motivates
you i mean the fact that he
you know he wasn't on a constant he was
in a concentration camp you've obviously
read the book and it's not a story about
the life in the concentration camp which
is horrific but the fact that he wanted
to live
he wanted to survive because he wanted
to recreate his work his manuscript was
taken from him when he was sent to our
switch in the first place
and part of what he learned when he was
in the concentration camp is that some
people gave up
and that even though the population in
the prison was jewish the mortality rate
actually increased around christmas and
new year
because it was a marking of time and a
reminder for people that they maybe had
no more hope or if they knew that their
family members had died
they gave up
so this idea that whatever it is that
motivates you it could
your purpose might be your company it
might be your family you know it might
be your hobby whatever it is but
identifying what it is that really
motivates you and leaning into that and
not pretending that you're actually
motivated by fame or fortune or some
other superficial
motivator i think it's just incredibly
clarifying
i'd like to ask you about
a term you used earlier
with reference to some of the other
general partners at sequoia the
relentless in pursuit piece
and
i'd like to ask about this because one
thing i've observed in
some of my friends who are serial
entrepreneurs who have had massive exits
i mean they they have become wealthy
beyond their wildest
dreams
is that this relentless in pursuit or
relentless pursuit can produce
incredibly good outputs in terms of
objective wealth creation job creation
solving problems in the world but it
doesn't always
translate and in fact it seems sometimes
to be inversely
correlated to contentedness
or
a feeling of peace or happiness
how do you think about if you do and
maybe the question is just the wrong
question but balancing
the relentless pursuit
or counterbalancing it
so that you don't always feel discontent
that's difficult because
if you're not a little discontent i
don't think you're alive
probably true
i mean
it's why people say oh silicon valley's
dead innovations that really like
there's so many problems to be solved
as long as they're problems they're
opportunities
yeah i don't think silicon valley's dead
or attack is dead no absolutely i think
the people that i found who ended up
getting unhappy
wasn't because they were still in
pursuit of something it's actually that
the pursuit was over
it's when you know because it's it's the
getting not the having
that makes you happy and so
unfortunately i've seen founders where
they've had a big exit and maybe the
company was acquired
and what do you do then
and
maybe you can borrow from analogies of
athletes often right the peak of their
careers when they're 28 or 32 whatever
the case is but they peak
relatively early in their life and then
are you the person who once was that as
opposed to what you are now and i think
that's very hard uh to deal with but
i've seen like the instagram founders
who i worked with you know
got involved with them very early and
they're just incredibly well adjusted
company was acquired it's been a huge
success
massive impact on the world and the two
of them are just building and having fun
and they've found all sorts of other
pursuits to keep them engaged and they
clearly haven't suffered from what i
described because they found another
outlet for meaning for themselves do you
remember when you hit your 10 to the
ninth
and could you
if you do could you tell us about that
experience
probably can't get you the precise year
but it was probably about five six years
ago
when i'd reached that i think it was
after the ipos of uh
mongodb and square now called block
i think after those two ipos and the
tara's ipo had achieved that milestone
well what what did you do
how did it feel did you pause to
celebrate or were you just like all
right now it's 10 to the 12th let's get
moving folks
um
i definitely celebrate it a little bit
but it's not over it's uh
because there are other interesting
companies to be built and and even more
importantly for those companies i'm
still on the boards of those companies
yeah because they're still so early in
their own innings
that there's so much more to be done at
these companies i think it's one of the
you know i don't know if we have time to
talk about the sequoia capital fund but
just part of the thing of all the time
in the world
[Laughter]
go for it yeah
yeah so last last year we conceived of
and launched this thing called the
sukhoi capital fund and
for a long time i've been frustrated
that the the venture capital model was
built on this idea of a 10-year
closed-end fund cycle and it was first
invented in the late 60s early 70s and
no one had questioned it
and there's this presumption that
because you have such a short-lived fund
life
that when the company goes public
you should distribute and move on to the
next thing
but the truth is that many of the great
companies endure and they keep
compounding and so with most of our
companies that have gone public the
majority of their market cap accrued
after the ipo not before the ipo square
today is worth
10 times what it was worth at the ipo so
almost definitionally 90 of its market
cap was created after the ipo so why why
sell after the ipo why leave the board
what about all the other fun company
building to be done i mean that's the
thing that really floats my boat is
working with entrepreneurs to help them
build businesses
and for me to have the founder call me
and say listen i'm resting with this
issue can you please help me that's one
of the
most gratifying things that i have in my
job
is being able to help on that journey
so what is the structure of the sequoia
capital fund
so the structure we created is
essentially an open-ended fund that will
become the sole investor
in all our future private funds so we'll
keep organizing private funds and part
of the reason is what we described
earlier if we have a single pool of
capital it dilutes attention and focus
so we'll still organize the seed fund
avenger fund and the growth fund and
those will be time-bound have dedicated
teams
a certain amount of money and it's
accountable for the returns that it
generates in a given vintage but all the
capital comes from a main sequoia
capital fund where we have cash but we
also have some of the long-standing
positions of our enduring businesses
but we believe the companies have an
ability to come compound for many years
after the ipo
so that's the spirit of the of the
investment structure
okay i i'd love to ask some probably
naive questions and and feel free to
give me a wrist slap if there's stupid
questions but i this is deeply
interesting to me so
the first question actually i'll just
give you two questions and you can
tackle them in whichever word you'd like
the first is
understanding and i have seen it might
have been published by sequoia it may
have been benchmark or someone else but
looking at
the financial outcomes if you had held
their private investments and sold as
soon as lock up expired when these
companies went public or if you had
invested the first day you could invest
in those companies and held for x number
of years and you would have made more
or just as much by investing as a public
market investor which blew my mind i
can't
recall the source but my question i
guess is with the assumption that a lot
of this value will accrue post ipo
why not just distribute in kind and then
let other people the lps decide if they
want to hold or sell and then the second
question is
the sequoia capital fund
and
presumably there are limited partners
entities institutions and maybe
individuals who invest in the squad
capital fund how do you pitch an
open-ended fund to
a pension fund or an endowment
yeah maybe you should spend a second
just on who our clients are so yeah
it's a query we work for what we call
great causes
so if you come to visit our office our
conference rooms
are actually named after our
long-standing limited partners
so the ford foundation the welcome trust
stanford university mit harvard denif
cancer institute boston children's
hospital these are the people we work
for got it and we put their names in the
door as a constant reminder that when we
generate returns
they're the ones who benefit
you know and there was a period actually
as a short digration a couple years ago
we thought about whether we had the
right fee structure for our business
because you know we capitalist we teach
our companies that they should figure
out the right price for their product
and we have excess demand for people
wanting to invest in our funds so why
don't we raise the prices why don't we
charge even more
could you just explain for people are
not familiar with venture capital just
the typical
fee structure or your fee structure at
the time so they understand how venture
capital firms make money
the typical structure is to charge
a management fee as a function of the
fund size so typically it's two to two
and a half percent
of whatever the fund size is that you
charge to pay for salaries and rent and
research all that sort of stuff and then
there's carried interest which is a
share of the profits if any that we
generate and the carried interest varies
between 20 and 30 based on a firm's
history and their performance history so
so let's just say that if you if you
invested 100 million and you turn it
into 200 and let's just say your carry
was 20 percent there's 20 million so
only 100 million of gan obviously 20
million would go to the partners and the
limited partners would get 180 million
in that scenario in that example got it
so that's how fee structure works so we
actually talked about whether we should
raise our fee structure
because people were still going to
invest in us and we actually made an
affirmative decision to not do that
because
we're very happy with what we earn and
we appreciate that the majority of what
we generate goes to great causes it goes
to education it goes to medical research
poverty alleviation the ford foundation
was helping to fight apartheid in south
africa in the 1960s before i was even
born so we're proud that these are the
people we work for because we've had
such a long history with them we invited
them to roll into the sequoia capital
fund and 95 of the dollars that were
eligible to roll into the square capital
fund did so
they are the same investors that have
rolled into the structure and we've had
decades of experience with them we have
clients that have been clients of ours
longer than i've been alive
and there'll be clients long after i've
gone and that's the way we want it we
want our lps to outlive our gps
gp is the general partner the people who
work at the partnership and we really
care about that that's part of this
long-term orientation we have at sequoia
do you want to go to the other question
yes please sure
so the reason we ended up with the
structure because it's a fair question
we talked about it you know let other
people decide why why should we hold the
shares you know
here xyzlp you can take the shares and
decide
if you're an endowment or a foundation
somewhere you're managing a couple of
billion maybe if you're a big university
endowment you have 20 billion or
something like that
you don't know
this latest company that we've just
distributed and so what we found is that
our lp's almost exclusively sell
as soon as we distribute
and part of what we observed we did
other analysis which is if we'd waited
12 months longer than we actually did to
distribute what additional return would
we have generated for our lpes and that
was a lot of what informed the decision
to form this fund i'll give you a
concrete example
at the point that
square went public
the gain for our limited partners was
about 140 150 million dollars
at ipo
and we waited
we waited several years in that case to
distribute
and we ended up generating well north of
a billion dollars for lps in that case
by being patient because i was on the
board i'm still on the board i'm
involved with the company i understand
their prospects and i just had a
different view that the company's share
price eventually was going to catch up
with its performance
so question on the research
if you look at the
data
and
you have each of your portfolio
companies
value at time of ipo and then there's
block up or whatever it might be and
let's just say
even if it's hypothetical that you do
the math on what the value would be at
that point and then 12 months later and
you've made the decision to
hold
what percentage of the time with your
portfolio companies to date roughly
would you say the value is higher
versus lower
after an additional say 12 month hold
period
i don't have the precise number at my
fingertips
but it's the majority yeah that's good
enough
the overwhelming majority i should say
yeah yeah
that's the case obviously you know
past is no guarantee of the future you
know disclaimer disclaimer
but do you think it's even more
important and i know if you've run
across this book by sebastian malibi
called power law of course it was
recently published you know it has been
recommended to me i'm sure it's amazing
his book more money than god on the
hedge fund industry i thought was
exceptional so i haven't yet read
the power law but it's been recommended
so that but please uh continue i'll
second the recommendation
the
i mean the reason he chose the title for
the book is that our our industry
follows a power law curve
so that they're
you know you know sequoia funds i can
just you know cite some of the
parameters roughly in a typical
venture fund that has let's just say 35
to 45 companies in a given vintage in a
given fund
we probably have a third of the
companies that fail to recover capital
which may mean there's a complete
write-off or it may mean we you know we
only realized 50 cents on every dollar
we invested but you know it's not a
success then there is a whole group of
companies that have modest success maybe
you get your money back maybe it's a 2x
or a 3x but what really drives the
performance of the fund is the typically
five to eight companies that end up
being 10x companies 10x returns
and the key is that the ones that are
that get to 10x sometimes run and they
become 55x they become 100x they become
200x returns and so you know when you
have
a youtube and airbnb uh
a unity a snowflake uh palo alto
networks whatsapp strive square you have
these companies they just they
completely blow it out on the on the
right hand side and so you get a power
low curve if you know look at it
mathematically it's just a very steep
curve where a small number of
investments really account for the
majority of our returns so in our
history between 5 and 15 of the
investments we make account for over 80
of the returns
sounds about right
and so to your question about holding
off to the ipo window it's not just that
the even if it's 50 50 whether it goes
up or down it's what's the asymmetry the
ones that keep compounding look at the
scale that has been achieved by a
company like google over time
right
like that's the kind of compounding
potential that exists not with all
businesses clearly there aren't too many
trillion dollar companies out there but
you know when you get them right they
can make a big difference
yeah the biggest takeaway for me and my
as i mentioned sort of amateur
tinkering in startup investing is
tim ferriss you don't know what the hell
you're doing with public investing do
not sell after lockup because you have
clearly no idea which companies are
gonna end up compounding incredibly all
of my worst mistakes
have been
panicking i shouldn't say panicking well
actually this is a perfect frame for a
question i wanted to ask you so
on one hand i can look at for instance
selling shopify right after lockup
in retrospect from my financial position
now and say that was a stupid mistake it
cost me 100 million plus dollars
i should have made a different decision
however i can also take
the counter position and make a very
compelling argument for why even though
now
it seems
like i made the wrong decision that the
absolute dollars at the time were a
life-changing amount for me then
and so it was a logical decision
and
i used that as a segue because
please correct me if this is
wrong but i found
a supposed quote from you which was you
know paypal was a 1.5 billion
acquisition and today it's a company
worth
over 300 billion i'm not sure of the the
timing of of this article and mike
moritz was on our board and mike i think
saw the potential and pushed us and
challenged us to think longer term
and what did we know what did i know and
i made the wrong decision and didn't
quite fathom how much potential paypal
had as a business
but
i imagine
that
it had a significant impact on your life
so i'd love to to know if you still feel
that was
the wrong decision and also how you
talk
to founders about this
because not every
slamming of the briefcase zuckerberg
style walking out on yahoo after a you
know a multi-billion dollar offer
works out sometimes it backfires
yeah so do you still think that was the
wrong decision for you and
if this quote is even accurate and how
do you talk to founders about this kind
of thing
so the question i ask founders is
my partners tease me because they know
that this is my question and it's what's
the scale of your ambition
what are you aiming to achieve are you
interested in a company that gets to 100
million in revenue and that's sort of
your that's the end of your ambition or
do you want to get you're going to blow
past 100 million in revenue on your way
to a billion in revenue quick question
i'm sorry
at what point do you ask them this
question because i imagine if it's in a
pitch meeting they know the right answer
but when are you asking them well in a
[ __ ] meeting often and and they may not
have thought about it and and it's not
to be critical i mean often when you're
a founder like you just found a problem
that you're passionate to solve
but i'm still interested to understand
like where do you want to take it
are you trying to build a small company
and again that's fine if you want to do
that but you know we're looking for
outliers who want to build really really
big businesses that's what the business
we're in and i want to make sure that
there's an alignment and that we're on
the same page
you know that your ambition matches what
we're looking for yeah
so so that is the scale of ambition
question
critically important question to try to
ensure to the extent possible that
you're on the same page let me
throw out just as a thought exercise
hypothetical right because i've seen it
happen with founders i know
they start off they have incredible
founder problem fit and in the beginning
their scope of ambition actually is
quite
modest right they just want to be able
to buy snowboards online or whatever the
hell it is right it's not to build an
enormous company
and then
partially through
competency partially through timing
partially through luck they end up
having tremendous traction
and then
let's say they
end up in a pitch meeting with you you
end up investing and then
a few years later fortunately the
company's doing really well
and they get an acquisition offer
and let's further say that these two
founders come from middle class families
maybe their parents made 50 grand a year
and one founder wants to
swing for the fences and say yolo it's
all or nothing although in this day and
age i mean they've probably taken some
money off with secondary and so on
but
let's say the other
really wants to cash out
because they're looking at how their
life would change and they're just
saying you know what this is a bird in
the hand
i don't know what the future holds
i want out
how do you navigate a situation like
that and maybe the
fast answer is if we can we just buy out
founder b
well no i don't but like how do you
handle a situation like that
you alluded to it secondaries are so
important
you know at paypal we did a small
secondary in 2001.
you know people talk about it as though
it's a recent invention
it was it was around
20 years ago and i remember going from
having been a student still paying off
student debt like my net worth was
negative
in 2001.
and we did a secondary and i think i got
50 000
i felt rich i mean it was it was
transformative i could actually travel
and i could stay in a hotel and it was
really amazing to have this experience
but the reason i mentioned this is
in the summer of 2001 ebay made a run at
us
in august
and i think part of what's different our
backbone was that we'd all taken a
little bit of money off the table we
were such a young team
and none of us worried about making rent
next month and it was a really important
i think ingredient to us pursuing the
ipo and getting a far better price we
got triple the price that they offered
that summer 12 months later so it was a
wise decision to have done that so i
love being able to provide secondaries
for people and then then there's a
conversation with people about the
meaning going back to viktor frankl you
know just what is it that you want to do
do you really think having the money and
having the beach house is going to make
you happy or buying this fancy car
because and what we often do is we'll
put them in touch with founders who've
been in that predicament
and have them speak to them talk about
the regrets
about maybe having sold too early
do they ever run into someone who says
you know what given your specifics
i think now is the right time
yes
[Music]
that does happen i mean and it's it's
part of what sorry to drive you i mean
that's part of what we try to do just
given our experience is try to to
shepherd the conversation and to let
people know look
we have this front row seat to hundreds
of portfolio companies i've got the
unfair advantage
that i've seen many many more companies
unfold than you have
the founder
you've obviously personally seen many
companies and so i can't give you a
perfect prediction but i've got to tell
you you're in this outlier category
you're in this one in 10 companies that
we see that really just has outsized
potential
and i think you're going to regret
letting go
and sometimes it's not the case we you
know we're valiant we made an effort we
thought you the company had a shot and
sort of it's ended up where it's ended
up and i think this is a good
acquisition offer it'd be a good home
for your team and your technology will
end up flourishing and with somebody
else at the helm and that's happened
sometimes where the companies have very
flourished
being acquired because that company has
the right distribution maybe for their
technology or
and that also is gratifying for the
entrepreneur because their creation sees
life
and flourishes not just because it's a
independent business
for people who don't know what secondary
transactions are would you mind just
defining that quickly i brought it up so
i should have defined it but yeah if you
would
you're far more qualified to do this so
if you wouldn't mind a primary issuance
of shares is when a company sells equity
in the business as part of raising
capital so the company sells
a million shares at ten dollars a share
and they actually raised ten million
dollars that goes into the coffers of
the company to help the company pay for
payroll and for helping to grow the
business a secondary transaction is
where the money doesn't end up in the
company's balance sheet but instead it's
just a secondary transaction between two
individuals that are unrelated so
an employee of the company a founder of
the company sells shares to somebody
outside who's interested in owning
shares in that company and so the
company doesn't raise money it's just
the founder sells you know 100 000 worth
of shares to an investor that might be
an example
perfect thank you for that
so we've talked about
the council you might provide
founders i'd like to turn that around
and
ask
if any founders come to mind who have
had a large impact on you in any
capacity and that doesn't need to mean
of course
through
the financial magnitude of their
outcomes
several i think
it's interesting one of my partners
actually pointed this out that when he
first got into the business he had this
impression that you should always
maintain a delineation between your
professional and your personal life and
that you shouldn't mix the two
and that he found it interesting that i
seem to be doing something different
because i was very close to the founders
i work with and
you know i
i'd help them with a pediatrician
recommendation or you know have dinners
with them on weekends or you know
sometimes travel with them
for family vacations and things like
that and so maybe it's just my style
i've ended up really enjoying the
long-term relationships i formed with
founders so we spoke about matter
benefits earlier the person i've met in
high school he's become a very dear
friend
given his background and genetics and
what he's exposed to in the healthcare
system he's actually volunteered
hours and hours over the last 12 months
helping me with a
close family member who has a medical uh
situation
and um
just
my heart
to see somebody who's so busy running a
company
make that kind of a sacrifice
i didn't even ask he just volunteered so
you know it's
through loyalty and being involved with
people for a long time that you can
build those sort of relationships to me
is deeply meaningful
the heart is who run eventbrite and
kevin was the the founder of a company
called zoom with an x not with a z uh
that we'd invested in as well they've
become close personal friends and
i don't know just it makes life so rich
when you can have these sort of
relationships with your founders and
that to me has been a
big part of the job honestly that i've
enjoyed is that something that comes
from your own family experience your
cultural upbringing is that something
you made
a point of doing in terms of fostering
these types of relationships after
arriving in the us where does that come
from
i think it's a talk i listened to from
esther perel i don't know if you know
her though i do i met her a couple years
ago and she talks about how you
sometimes grow up in a society or in a
family where this is the balance around
relationships or transactions
you know you can imagine some cultures
are very transactional and you're
fearful and it's you know you're out on
your own or you're in a society or in a
family or a culture that is more
nurturing and it's more about
relationships and i think i grew up with
relationships
and so i think it's part of part of the
way i grew up that i value those
so i think it's informed the way that i
behave in business too
let's zoom back for a minute as this is
as opportune to time as any so
am i correct that you did not grow up
speaking english at home
correct okay so for most people
listening i would imagine they don't
have
much context
on
your
home culture could you perhaps describe
some of the
characteristics defining characteristics
of the culture within which you grew up
in the same way that if someone said hey
you lived in japan for a year what are
some of the defining characteristics i
could pull out a few things that i think
really characterize and and set it apart
in a sense how would you do that for the
culture in which you grew up
for the afrikaner culture that's right
yeah
uh so i had a family level
it
i guess started off with a bump my mom
was 16 when i was born my dad was 18.
so i doubt it was planned
she finished the high school
with me
and needless to say they were young and
in love but probably not compatible so a
couple of years later they got divorced
and
my mom moved back with her parents
who by then were the early 40s so i you
know they were in some sense also an
extra set of parents for me and they had
a huge influence in in raising me and my
grandmother in particular was just an
incredibly warm gregarious person you
know everybody knew who she was and
maybe some of the the loyalty that i
that i
exhibit in the way that i operate came
from her
either genetically or through
living with her
so it was a very warm family it was a
sort of family where if a friend or a
distant relative showed up on a random
thursday night you just assumed that you
had enough food to cook for them and
that you were going to have a dinner
together it was that kind of an
environment
there were always people around always
people visiting
but then my mom remarried and we moved
to another town that was about a
thousand miles away from pretoria where
i had been born and
hence i needed to start to speak english
because i moved to a city that was
predominantly english not having spoken
it before
but it meant that i grew up in a
different place and i was a bit of an
outsider i was prejudged especially in
the community that viewed itself as more
liberal there's a sense in which my
grandfather was viewed as being very
conservative because he served the
national government and so i faced an
enormous amount of prejudice where i
always felt as though people
judged me before taking the time to get
to know me
and that i had to earn their trust and
and sort of show who i was over and over
and that was daunting in some respect
but i definitely felt like a bit of an
outsider when i moved to a new city
i went to an afrikaans high school
and then i realized that if i wanted to
live abroad eventually i needed to
improve my english so i chose to go to
an english university the university of
cape town
purposefully
and just to give you a sense of the
challenge i got a i remember in first
year math i got a problem wrong
because i literally didn't know what the
word isosceles meant because i done math
in afrikaans in high school and we had a
completely different word to describe an
isosceles triangle and i lit i mean i
could solve the problem but i didn't
know what the word meant and these are
the sort of little things that you trip
up trip over you try to switch your
principal language but
now
i remember you
mentioning
and i'm not going to get this perhaps
exactly right but you want it to be top
10
in the state or the province of the
region and then you wanted to be
number one
in
college or university am i getting that
right
why do you go from top ten to number one
not number one number one
did you start raising your sights or was
it easier because the pool was smaller
i'm just i'm curious because you seem
like a
you know second place as first loser
kind of guy not to project you know but
i'm just curious how you went from top
10 to number one so the end of high
school you
unlike the us where you write standard
you know sats and acts i'm not learning
because i have kids that are
eventually needing to go to college all
these new things i have to learn about
but in south africa you write
standardized exams at the end of high
school so you know if you're doing math
everybody writes the same math paper and
it gets graded by people that are not
affiliated with your school for
neutrality
and so
i was difficult because you you know i
was doing english as a first language
even though i was an african speaker and
you know you've got languages you've got
you know i knew i could do well in math
and science and things like that but it
was a bit of a crapshoot to know if
you'd get number one
and i only published the top 20.
but i thought i could make the top 10.
so that i thought it was a realistic
honesty
when you get to university you know you
could choose your subjects a little more
purposefully and i knew that you know
within that cadre of studying actual
science
maybe i knew who the individuals were
and i became maybe i became too cocky
maybe it was dangerous but i thought i
could be number one so
that was my goal
this is going to seem like a bizarre
question but since you brought up your
kids
i read that at some point they were
raising south african silkworms now i
wasn't even aware that silkworms were a
thing in south africa
how how did your kids end up raising
south african silkworms it's just not
the first thing that comes to mind when
i think of pet not to malign
uh south african silkworms as pets
they went to the african silicons i mean
i bought them here in the u.s
okay this is hilarious and then i read
whatever source i had had them down is
south african pilgrims so i'm like wow i
had no idea okay that makes more sense
last time i checked they came from asia
anyway yeah right i don't know who you
know i mean there was a secret in china
right they had all these all these
walled off gardens because they didn't
want western traders to understand where
silk actually came from this is true it
was hidden secret from the west for a
long time so
i guess when i was a kid we had
it's just one of the things you do is
you learn about silkworms and you you
buy a couple of eggs from somebody in
primary school and there are enough
mulberry trees around so you can feed
them and you actually observe the the
full life cycle and eventually they
become moths and mate and lay their eggs
and die and so anyway i thought it'd be
fun to do with them except in my typical
eyes bigger than my mouth fashion we
ended up with a complete
mess
because we had
thousands of silk
to the point that little mulberry tree
we had in our garden couldn't provide
enough trees so i was driving around the
neighborhood in los altos
and i would try to find mulberry trees
that had overreached the the boundaries
or you know people maybe fences and i
would go there with bags
because steel leaves
capitalist caught stealing mulberry
leaves
[Laughter]
that is really funny but it was actually
found by the way my daughter ended up
writing experiments for them so you know
you get white ones and you get zebra
ones we call them zebra ones they're
white with little black stripes and my
daughter ended up running experiments
where she segregated them to see how the
genetics would line up so she was doing
a little controlled experiment which was
probably a clue that she wanted to be in
biology eventually
well you know if dad's reading the
america's best nature and science
writing on an annual basis well this
leads me to want to ask about questions
about interests outside of
say venture capital or
investing if you were invited to give a
ted talk on the main stage but you could
not talk about
investing
what topic
might you choose
probably genetics
i'm really fascinated by what's
happening in the field of genetic
engineering please elaborate yeah i mean
we happen to have a company in this
space
that's helping with you know delivery of
crispr but i mean that's
the point is not about investing it's
about
programmability of biology and it's the
reason i got interested in
having us invest in atera a long time
ago as i was starting to read about
genetics not having studied biology at
college
because i went in a different direction
but when the human genome project
concluded it really opened my eyes to
what was possible with the information
that we have in genetics and so
whether that's for diagnostic purposes
but now the ability to engineer to treat
disease and there was just the drug
approved today actually for treating
blood-borne
cancer disease that is reliant on
genetic engineering so this idea that we
can treat human disease with
precision genetic engineering absolutely
blows my mind
so that's the field that i want to study
if i had infinite time
what would the runner-up be
do you have any other
pet obsessions
former potential career tracks that you
give up on
or put aside if you want to put it that
way
anything else that would be runner-up
uh
i love rugby rugby
i really love rugby because i grew up in
south africa it's the afrikaner sport of
choice at some level i think when i
moved to the united states it was one of
those anchors back it was a bridge back
to the country for me it was something
for me to talk about with my brothers
and my dad and my grandfathers
gave me an excuse to keep in touch with
the country and so it's an unnatural and
unhealthy obsession i realized but i do
love the sport and i used to play uh
until i got a pretty bad concussion if
you could see this little grace patch
over here yeah is that really from the
impact no really yeah i i was playing
for stanford and i got a spear tackle
right on this spot and i was knocked
unconscious
9-1-1 ambulance showed up i woke up two
hours later and i was inside a ct
scanner and i had no idea where i was
and after three four months of
persistent headaches
i realized that
was the end of my non-money-making rugby
playing days but i'm certainly an
enthusiast as a spectator you know i
will say for most of my life knew
nothing about rugby and then in the
process of doing research for
the four-hour body my second book spent
time in south africa at the sports
at the south african sports science
institute with
a professor i think he was a professor
at least a phd name folks tim knox
exactly right yeah yeah he's well known
yeah with tim nooks and did all sorts of
tests and proved through muscle biopsy
that effectively my enzyme levels are
worse than homer simpson it turns out
but in the process i was able to watch
the
springbok
sevens
team
warm up and train and i have to say
easily some of the most impressive
athletes i've ever witnessed in my life
just in terms of
combination of strength agility speed
endurance
absolutely
mind-blowing
and
still couldn't tell you how the game is
played other than throwing the ball
underhand
but
but beyond that
but maybe just integration that for a
second when i was a kid in primary
school i was starting to do well
academically and playing chess and doing
these sort of things and i had a teacher
who pulled me aside and really
encouraged me to play rugby because he
was worried that i was going down a path
of doing things that were very academic
and individualistic
and he encouraged me to play rugby and
you know i played all the way through
high school and grew to love the sport
but part of it was it was a way to bond
with people from every demographic in my
school
i didn't go to an academic school i went
to a public school in south africa and
so we had people who were not
academically gifted but i play with them
they'd be my teammates and i had very
little in common with them if we weren't
playing rugby but it enabled me to form
relationships and bonds with people and
the sport itself
is not about individual attribution it's
all about the team winning
no one cares who scored the try
everybody cares that the team won and so
it had a lot to do with my approach to
business and the way that we think about
managing our team at sequoia as well
what are your
current
exercise or movement
routines
if
if any i don't have much to report so i
i shouldn't uh i should say with full
disclosure i mean look i'm not
intimidated no i'm not fully sedentary
but i mean i wouldn't say i'm exactly
winning any ironmans anytime soon so i'm
just curious as as part of self-care
what types of of physical routines
are
important to you or consistent for you
i exercise at least four or five times a
week
an hour or more each time if i can on a
weekend especially if i'm watching a
rugby match i'll i'll burn a thousand
calories
doing all sorts of different things
which is very helpful by the way because
if your team loses you're too exhausted
to be angry
at the end of the workout wait are you
doing like jumping jacks and push-ups
while you're watching rugby what does
this look like no if i'm watching a game
i'll alternate between a treadmill a
rowing machine and an assault bike one
of those air bikes yeah absolutely i'll
spend 20 minutes on each and i'll just
keep rotating but you know you're sort
of sustained a heart rate at like 140
145 and you're just spent at the end of
that and drenched but um
no more energy to be angry and then i
work you know part of the beauty is
honestly of what's happened with covert
and you know obviously terrible
humanitarian disaster but the side
effect has been that they're all these
trainers that are available on zoom now
and so
you know i'll pop up you know an ipad in
the gym and train with a trainer who
just changes the workout routine and a
lot of functional training as well
because i think especially someone gets
a little older you know things like
balance and
making sure you have good core strength
and
anyway i i love exercise i absolutely
love exercise and i love snowboarding by
the way which is something i didn't know
i had not touched snow until i was 24
when i first came to the us wow and a
friend of mine
at uh
business school convinced me to go up to
tahoe for a weekend uh i went for five
days thinking i would
figure it out in five days but i was so
sore that i couldn't go on days two and
four i could only go every other day i
was in pain
but now i can get up to about 60 miles
an hour on a snowboard which is fun and
dangerous
braver man than i that's for sure
and it's the only sport i dream about
it's fascinating i have to
just point out that you stopped playing
rugby because you had a concussion but
you're going 60 miles an hour of
snowboard i hope you're wearing a helmet
oh yes
yeah and i love
moving
quickly on snow i just have taken a
little pause because i actually tore my
right labrum snowboarding last winter so
it's it's it's feeling good i'm going to
get back on the snow but i'm going to
stick to the two sticks and probably
keep on the skis uh for for a bit before
trying any any snowboarding again
i'd love to ask you a question that i
think you ask
of i want to say founders reasonably
frequently and i i'm sure i'm going to
get the phrasing wrong but
the question relates to
key
career
decisions and maybe you can
tell me first how you actually ask it
but i would just love to know how you
would answer the question of
absolute key
watershed decisions
in your career if one or two
float to the top of the list
we call them crucible moments at sequoia
crucible moments perfect and my partner
jim gates actually is the one who came
up with that i'm not going to claim
credits he deserves credit for the the
phrase
and we applied to business context by
the way
and
to answer your question but i think it's
really important for companies to think
about crucible moments because often
they don't even identify them they don't
realize that they face a crucible
decision whether it's geographic
expansion product expansion a key shift
that the business must make i'm not
talking about pivots where what you try
doesn't work it's it's something really
different at mongodb the decision to
become a cloud business was a crucible
decision at square the decision to build
cash app as a personal
uh individual product rather than an smb
product that was a crucible decision
very difficult to pull off within the
company
but these decisions end up having a huge
bearing on the ultimate outcome of a
company and so do they with careers and
so when i interview somebody for example
i don't focus on you know tell me
everything that happened while you were
at this job tell me why you chose this
job
how did you find this opportunity what
else were you thinking about and what is
it about this particular opportunity
that attracted you why did you go to the
school
and why did you not go to that school
those are the more interesting questions
they're also indisputable because that's
what you actually did you know you can't
tell me that you know what am i good at
oh i'm a perfectionist okay great you
know that's just a glib answer to the
question
so for me the crucible decisions
one of them was to join mckinsey
when i qualified as an actuary i took a
50 pay cut relative to what i would have
been earning as an actor to join
mckinsey
and i had to pay back the bursary that
i'd gotten from the insurance company so
it was a double whammy financially and
the bursary is effectively a scholarship
college yeah but you have to pay back if
you don't go work for them so the the
deal was that they would pay for my
tuition and i had to work for them for
the same number of years that i studied
to pay off the debt and if i didn't work
for them i literally had to pay them
back every penny and so
so i earned less and had the debt to pay
off i made the same decision when i
joined paypal
so i had
mckinsey was paying for some of my
tuition at stanford and i had to pay
them back
and what i was getting i still have my
offer letter elon recruited me to to
paypal slashx.com and i have the signed
offer letter still on my door and
i got eighty thousand dollars that was
my salary when i finished my mba in 2000
and it was less than mckinsey was going
to pay me
and i had to mckinsey back
and then the third one was joining
sequoia and those are the three key
career decisions
that was that
how did you end up in silicon valley
i had a it was a funny story there was
an american who'd come to university of
cape town when i was an undergrad
and he was a guest lecturer in economics
his name is peter baird
and it was fascinating to meet him he
had a wonderfully bubbly personality and
he was just one of these larger than
life people i loved working for him well
i ended up working for him later as i'll
explain he ended up working in mckinsey
coming to south africa and i was staffed
on a project with him where he was my
engagement manager
and he convinced me that i should apply
to business school because i'd done a
business undergraduate what is an
engagement manager
just before we
jump over that what does that mean
an engagement in mckinsey language was a
project basically so he was the project
manager they just needed to come up with
fancy words to merit the exorbitant fees
that we're charging
yes got it so sorry to interrupt yeah no
problem so he was the project manager he
convinced me i should apply to business
school which i didn't think was
necessary because i'd done a business
undergraduate as part of my actual
science training and he wrote on my
recommendation letters and strongly
encouraged me to to think about coming
to stanford and at that point this was
in the late 90s obviously stanford or
silicon valley in general looked like an
interesting place this was the
the well of opportunity so many
companies were being formed
it's instinctively it seemed like the
place to be
and so that's why i got to stanford in
1998.
wow
1998 you know it's
easy for me to forget how
young you are i mean for for me right
it's just looking at your
bio and resume it's crazy to think you
got there in 98
i got there
in 2000 i mean at the end of 99 2000 it
would have been in 2000 so not that long
afterwards and how old are you now if i
may ask
48
48 man overachiever okay so you get to
silicon valley
now up to that point
your decisions seem to be very
methodical you're thinking about
preserving optionality
and mitigating certain risks
as you explained earlier with
the political climate
changes taking place
choice of mckinsey
how do you then was the intention from
the get-go to go to business school and
join a startup before you even got to
the west coast nope
okay
okay so how do we go from that
to
speculative
of course because they all are
speculative startup
you need to change your mind if we talk
about mentors by the way i have a
specific anecdote about one of them that
really hammered this into me but right
before i came to business school i was
doing
a master's degree which i didn't
complete
at the university of cape town on
long-term option pricing using
stochastic simulation techniques
you too
no i'm kidding just kidding
got it
sorry i screwed up the flow
it's what one does on a weekend you know
you run these monte carlo simulations on
your little compact
laptop
i was fascinated by
finance serious finance and i thought
i'd end up in wall street and work in
the derivatives group somewhere and
when i was a first year business school
actually i was doing advanced topics and
derivatives and ended up taking all the
finance classes and i thought that would
be where i could shine because you know
you know got
mathematical skills i thought it was
interesting it was fascinating i
actually spent my summer working in
london at goldman sachs when i was in
business school i thought you know is
europe interesting i didn't know
is banking interesting i didn't know
and
i've got a no on both of those by the
way so i tried it
no meaning you gave it a shot and got
rejected is that what you mean by a no
no no i realized that that was not the
right calling going back to europe at
that point to me felt like going back to
the past as opposed to the future and
the west coast was the future okay
because the the figuring out those were
not the right paths is very critical
right i don't want to gloss over that so
could you
expand on that was was europe as you
said felt like going to the past instead
of the future and that's how you arrived
at an o for that option yep okay and for
me as a south african it was the many
south africans that live in the uk it's
same time zone essentially south africa
and so it was closer to home i mean
california is about as far as you can
get from where i grew up and my family
and i was very close to my family and so
i was wondering if that made sense and
so i tried it got enough information to
realize that was not my destiny and so
i came back
for second year one of my classmates
had met elon
before he came to business school when
elon rans up to and this friend of mine
was at city search and introduced me to
elon
and i thought the intersection of
financial services and technology was
interesting and he made me a job offer
and i couldn't quit because i didn't
have a work permit i was here on a
student visa
and so
you know we kept in touch and i started
to learn more about paypal i was really
intrigued when paypal and x.com came
together because i loved the business
model that that had and
at that point when he made me another
offer and the opportunity was
actually to report to peter
peter thiel
that seemed like something i shouldn't
turn down so i accepted the offer and i
was so delighted they took a chance on
me
why did it seem like something you
shouldn't turn down because you know
elon and peter were not the elon and
peter in all marquee lights
of today
no no no just earlier obviously i love
the business model and let me be clear i
still vacillate it because you know i
had to pay back an enormous amount of
student debt i didn't have any money
i'd run out of money actually in second
year of business school and was living
off borrowed funds from friends of mine
and i was struggling to make rent
it was tough did your family know this
they did they didn't have money i didn't
grow up with wealth right understood
said i'm wondering what your family
assuming you were in contact with them
what did they
what did they say about this how did
those conversations go were they worried
about they were supportive yeah yeah
they were of course they were worried
but they i mean they didn't have the
means right to be able to support me so
you know peter baird the person who i
worked for at mckinsey he lent me some
money my best friend who was working in
london at that point was my best man
when i got married he lent me some money
my now wife who was a classmate
we were dating already she lent me some
money it was embarrassing at some level
but i you know i had to get through and
so i was struggling with the decision
because it was an expensive decision to
walk away from going back to mckinsey or
maybe joining goldman and so i struggle
with those two choices and the choice to
go to a startup and my wife actually
studied computer engineering at kaniki
melon who's also an immigrant from
singapore
she and i had long conversations and she
really encouraged me to take the startup
round and she'd worked at startups
before she came to business school we
were classmates we'd met there and so
she was a huge influence i made that
decision
i liked the business that they were
building it was clear that the payments
piece
was a way to make
well there was a clear path to turning
it into a revenue business
i thought that the combination of x and
paypal would really dominate the pdp
payment space and i fell in love with
the business and the people
was there ever a moment
in the first handful of years where you
second guessed
that decision do any particular two
weeks later
two weeks later
i said that my offer letter was signed
on march 30th 2000.
april 12 the nasdaq has a massive
correction
i mean literally two weeks later
then i go to a class where meg whitman
was a guest speaker in one of the
classes i was taking at stanford i'd
already accepted my offer to join and
she came to this class and she says well
we own this payment service called
bullpoint and we're going to crush this
annoying little startup in palo alto
called paypal
don't say that it's like i'm gonna go
work there
i thought we played nice in silicon
valley what's going on here
so
then we had the fraud challenges then
the our burn rate was 14 million dollars
in june 2000. before we started to
charge for payments and our burn rate
was accelerating could you explain the
the fraud challenges just so people
don't
misinterpret what that means so firstly
paypal wasn't generating revenue yet so
whenever somebody
accepted a transaction on paypal
it just says 100 transaction roughly
speaking two and a half percent was the
fee that goes back to the credit card
associations and the issuer of the
credit card so
we were paying that 2.50 for every
single transaction that was happening on
paypal and never charging the recipient
the merchant for the transaction so our
losses were growing very very quickly
and then we were dealing with two types
of fraud the first is unauthorized fraud
this is where somebody stole your credit
card number enters it onto the paypal
website at that time charges a hundred
dollars and withdraws the money and runs
away and then you get your credit card
statement at the end of the month and go
i didn't authorize this transaction you
file a charge back paypal was in the
hook to pay you back your hundred
dollars so we had to protect against
this unauthorized fraud use case and
then there's merchant fraud which is you
know the person said they'd ship you
something it never arrived it arrived
damage it didn't look the way it did on
the website things like that
so you have
was it a crisis of faith or were you
like hmm not sure about this like how
severe
was the
second guessing
well i never thought about quitting by
the way it was more just
i'm not sure we're gonna make it i might
have to
row a boat back to south africa okay
why never consider
quitting this is interesting to me
not saying you should have quit clearly
it worked out but
why
the stick-to-itiveness
despite
all of the challenges
the massive nasdaq correction
why never thought of quitting
i don't know we were i felt like we were
in it together as a team
we had incredible spirit and camaraderie
within the building
i felt like we had each other's backs we
became good friends i mean it's part of
the reason i think the paypal mafia was
as successful as it was as we formed
incredibly strong bonds then
i don't know we just rallied as a team
and we sort of felt we're going to build
this and if we don't build it we're
going to you know we'll go down with the
ship rather than abandon ship
that was just a sentiment so we just
kept trying you know problem of the
problem whether it was fraud whether it
was ebay trying to kill us whether it
was regulators whether it was visa
we just kept fighting
i don't know maybe we're too naive to
understand that it was foolish well i
mean i think that
goes for a lot of founders who end up
doing very well
there are people with creative projects
i mean you hear it all the time it's
kind of cliched at this point i guess
but if
if they had known what was involved at
the outset they never would have done it
right but they did it yeah also
so
we're talking about paypal clearly all's
well that ends well
and i'd like to try to flesh you out a
little bit as as a a human
as opposed to
someone who
steps up and hits home runs non-stop
which you've had a lot of home runs to
be clear but
do you have or could you describe
a
meaningful or favorite failure and by
that i mean
any
anything that seemed like a failure at
the time or was a failure
that
was particularly valuable
for you looking back
or that set you up in some fashion for
later success does anything come to mind
did you say favorite failure
did you say that those are the words i
used yes
failing sucks
it's painful i mean it is
yes we can definitely re
label it however you like but yeah
in effect i say that whimsically partly
because i really hate losing time
intensely
also something common for quite a few
members of the paypal mafia
yeah which you know has its downsides
obviously so you know
one of the things we talk about in our
partnership is the sins of commission
and the sense of omission
and the sense of commission is we made
an investment we shouldn't have
and the sins of our mission are the ones
you didn't but should have
and
i've probably made six seven investments
in my career already that literally went
to zero
and
i don't think i should really highlight
any of them because you know we made a
good try the founders were great didn't
quite work out and it was valiant we did
what we we could i will tell you that
the first time i had an investment that
went 2-0 it was a 10 million complete
write-off i literally cried in our
partner meeting because i had such such
an immense sense of shame
and guilt for having failed
and for having lost money for unlimited
partners and it was an important moment
partly because my
the senior partners at sequoia i think
part of it we do well as a team part of
our longevity is the way that we help
each other and so senior partners who
had gone through this themselves were
there to support me and to you know
guide me through this because the danger
in the business is if you've had an
experience like that is you recoil
and and you become very careful and
you'll never
get back to the glory days maybe like an
athlete who has a severe injury and they
never want to test that knee again you
know because they had a bad knee injury
or something they'll never attain what
they had in the past so so that to me
was a very painful experience but the
ones that really sting are the ones we
should have made and i think back to
meeting jack when he was at twitter
i met him and ev and we had an
opportunity to invest in the series a
twitter this is in 2007
so this is before the iphone was
released there was no twitter app this
was text messaging
different business
and i just didn't dream enough i failed
to imagine what might happen with a
service like this
and that was incredibly painful for me
and we missed the a
and we missed the b and we missed the c
and that was a huge lesson for me and i
you know sometimes you can explain away
an investment you didn't make by saying
well x anti were those same facts would
you make the same decision today or not
because obviously x post you should have
made the investment but x anti you know
sometimes things just you know they're
weird twists and turns in the on the
road to company building
and so maybe you could justify that the
series a was you know
a bit more random because it took a lot
from there to where they were in say
2010
but by 2010 we should have looked at it
and reevaluated our decision
and that i feel really guilty for that
was terrible
i really really messed up
for not revisiting assumptions what did
you learn from that in terms of things
that you discounted that you shouldn't
have things that were invisible that you
should have made visible
i'm wondering what you carry forward
from that
the two things are imagination dreaming
sitting back for a second and saying
and my partner mike maris often hammers
this home for us in our partner meetings
when when he was part of the team
full-time was
you know what if it goes right
because we can all you know we're in the
business of investing we're in the
business of not investing so assume for
a second goes right what could you
imagine this being
just imagine for a second instead of you
know you know it's the pre-parade
exercise in some sense just put on your
thinking caps i remember being in a
meeting with mike
and max lefton and jeremy stoppelman
when yelp was an idea
an idea
in 2005
and mike in a meeting said
i imagine a future where there are yelp
stickers outside restaurants
i mean that was an amazing insight and
amazing vision for the future which came
to be true
and so i'm always reminded about the
need for imagination in our business
then the need to be naive at some level
if you become a curmudgeon in the
venture business you're done
you need to be naive you need to dream
so that's the one the second one is
learning a little bit from behavioral
economics of the need to revisit your
assumptions
so i was really stuck in a some cost
fallacy where i'd made a decision to you
know my recommendation was for us to not
invest wrong decision
so let's dig my head into the ground and
hide and just keep saying we shouldn't
invest we shouldn't invest because why
admit that i was wrong
and so you need to be able to revisit
your decision and admit you were wrong
so we got the series they had square on
and we corrected it and we paid up for
the series b and i helped lead the
investment and i had to swallow my pride
i'm sorry team i should have recommended
it nine months ago
my bad now we're paying a high price for
the investment but i still believe in it
and i think that's huge upside and
psychologically that's a very difficult
thing for people to do and so we want to
create that kind of safety for us in our
investment team
we're going to come back to changing
your mind
and before we get to that though i just
want to read something that i think
is
profound which i'd never really thought
of before this is from don valentin
and i am paraphrasing here but
i understand that
he said to you at some point maybe in
the interview process
that
successful people join venture capital
only to have to face the fact that good
investing means taking risks and
startups that are more likely than not
to fail you know coming to grips with
being wrong not five percent of the time
but thirty percent of the time forty
percent of the time
really eats at your self confidence i
think that's a quote from you actually
uh
so you had this
experience of crying in the partner
meeting did it continue to be
difficult
i suppose i'm wondering if there was a
moment
a particular company
when you can identify that use you
became more comfortable
with some of your portfolio companies
going to zero is there anything that
helped with that aside from the support
of the partners say in that particular
meeting
it wasn't the support of the partner
just in that meeting in general i think
we started to have conversations about
not doing post-mortems
because at one point we had an exercise
of doing post-mortems on investments you
know we got this one wrong let's hammer
into each other while we got it wrong
and what does that breed that reads a
culture where people are going to be
scared
scared to take chances and if you're
dealing in a power law business with
asymmetric upside
like why why cry over the yet another
one that failed you need to focus on the
ones that really succeed that's where
the business is won now obviously if all
you do is you make you know a dozen
investments that don't work out then you
probably need to go to something else
with your time so you need to get enough
ones that are good obviously to survive
so that was part of it we stopped doing
post-mortems we and we supported each
other it was clear to me that my
partners weren't judging me and that my
head wasn't on the block for the next
failure i felt secure enough that i
could make decisions and knew that i was
part of the team it wasn't as though
maybe you want to use a sports analogy
if you go for a crazy shot are you going
to be cut from the starting team next
game
no because you took a rational shot it
maybe didn't drop that time and there
are probably a million michael jordan
quotes you can use that
make that point so that was one piece
the other one was at some point you have
enough success where you realize well i
made an investment that made us 500
million dollars that excuses
three of those failed five million
dollar investments like many times over
right and so you just you have to get
over it yeah you just psychologically
have to accept that you just have to
move on from that failure and not have
it encumber you learn from it don't
dismiss it
but you just rationally have to look at
the math and go okay next
and so part of what helped me by the way
i was in the doldrums in 2009 i actually
thought about quitting the business you
know youtube was a great success early
on in my career it was a you know i was
incredibly fortunate to have had such a
big success within my first three years
as a venture investor
and and then i had a pretty lean backlog
and i wasn't sure i was cut out for it
you know
one hit wonder is this going to be one
and done
and then you know i kept at it and i
realized there's always another red bat
in our industry
so in 2009 after i thought about it
after my partner doug and mike and jim
really pulled me out of my doldrums we
ended up investing in unity and
eventbrite and square and mongodb
and a you know list of companies and it
was just this purple patch of investing
and so just reminded me you know just
don't give up keep going how did they
pull you out of your doldrums what did
they say do you remember anything
specific even if it's paraphrased or a
rough guesstimate what did they actually
say to you
well there's a balance that we have of
i've not learned
since i've been here long enough to
recognize when other people go through
this as well
and
you know you can't cuddle
you can't be there with you know
making it too safe too many boundaries
too many guard rails people actually
have to walk through a little bit of the
valley of just despair on their own and
wrestle with it but at one point jim
realized that i was going too far and he
would take me for walks around the
office i don't remember the specifics of
what he talked about but i remember him
spending a lot of time in investing and
trying to get me into the right space
and then doug lee only showed up at my
house one day
with homemade pesto
and he was knocking on the door on a
saturday i honestly didn't feel like
opening the doors like leave me
i want to be miserable by myself
and you know doug knocked and he had
literally from basil that he grew in his
own garden he brought this little jar of
pesto for me which was delicious but it
was the the sign that he was there for
me
and knew what i was going through and
that that it was memorable
and had a big impact
so mentors
you mentioned changing your mind is
important and you said let's come back
if you like to mentors because you have
one in mind
do you still have that thread if so
would you like to
pick up on that
peter thiel
so peter came back as a ceo if you've
read any of the paypal books and know
the story you know
we as a team rally to get him back as
ceo it was difficult because the board
wasn't fully supportive and we had to
keep as a team we had to keep
interviewing other candidates and we
kept feeling no but peter
we're a team and peter's peter's our man
and we want peter to be our leader and
our ceo and so
peter had incredible ability to change
his mind
peter would say we're turning left we're
turning left and then you know we
weren't sure we'd go analyze bring him
data we'd show him the results and he'd
say yep i've just looked at it returning
right and he would just turn like that
on a dime and he had no qualms about
this and i think most people get so
stuck in escalation of commitment where
i need to remain consistent with the
person you thought i was yesterday
otherwise i'm going to be viewed as
irrational there's a whole branch of
psychology that talks about this
right and to some extent people view
flip-floppers negatively especially in
politics and things like that but in
business it's incredibly valuable if
you're just rational and peter did that
to a t and made him an incredible ceo
do you think that's just peter out of
the box different motherboard different
programming or is that something that he
cultivated and if you think there's a
component of it that is cultivated
how do you think he did that or how
would you help someone to develop
that ability
so i don't know if because i obviously
didn't know him growing up i've you know
met him in the paypal context so
i mean peter's just so supremely smart
and rational that i my guess is it's
innate in him and he just he doesn't
suffer that kind of baggage if you will
yeah
and he thinks for himself i think
there's a lot of people that are so
worried about what others think of them
and peter just doesn't seem encumbered
by that not that he's indifferent to it
but i just don't think he spends his
whole life worrying about what others
think about him he just does what he
thinks is right
and and interesting yeah
so
i think it's innate i think in terms of
cultivating it
just calling it for what it is
you know in an organization creating a
culture where you're willing to stand up
to new information and change your mind
and then praising people for changing
their mind on things
you know look i i said no to this
decision i've reevaluated or i walked
into the partner meeting thinking we
shouldn't make this investment
and i've been swayed by your arguments
or recognizing that somebody else
changed their mind and praising them for
doing that i think you need to cultivate
that kind of culture
yeah agreed
i find it so
fascinating i'm gonna sit with this
because it makes perfect it makes
perfect sense although i have some
misgivings so let's come back to it then
not doing postmortems
psychologically
it makes a lot of sense to me that if
you
over emphasize
postmortems
you could
you could breed
fear in those who you want to take risks
and therefore it's self-defeating
but i suppose there's some
post-mortem required to then at least on
an individual level to change your mind
about a company that you said no to
or there's a revision of your thinking
that needs to take place
how did you if any companies come to
mind or it doesn't need to be a specific
company but
what is the process that you
that you have gone through to
change your mind to kind of revisit
assumptions for any any of those
investments where you turn down
c to the series a and then you end up
paying up on a series b or series c
it takes work by the way i don't pretend
that it's easy and that it just comes
naturally i think we've evolved with all
these heuristics and they maybe served
us well 200 000 years ago when we first
evolved as a species but it hampers us
today so i i have to fight it the whole
time you know we'll start discussing a
company that i remember meeting nine
months prior and i can just feel my
instincts like no i didn't like it then
why should i like it now
why do i have to work and think about it
again i mean the lazy part of me just
wanted to say no like i really made the
decision move on right and so it takes
effort it really takes effort but that's
part of why heuristics are valuable
right the shortcuts
and for many things in life shortcuts
are great but if you want to make
important decisions maybe shortcuts are
a curse and so anyway so i i don't make
it sound like i'm you know it just comes
naturally
by the way we do do lightweight
post-mortems on the things that failed
when we made an investment it was just
that we used to have this exercise which
is the sponsor has to go write a memo
and you know mayor cooper right there's
a punishment
or maybe not punishment that might be
too dramatic but there was a
dire consequence
it was just too much it was just too
much we have to learn from them you know
so we got the space right but we picked
the wrong team why did we pick the wrong
team oh they had better technology but
they didn't have the right go to market
capabilities or you know they they aimed
at the wrong part of the value chain
like you know we try to learn from those
because it informs future decisions so
so don't make it sound like we're
oblivious to the mistakes of the past
but it's then re-looking at a company
you know the
it's one of the things we analyzed
recently
i can't remember when we did this
particular analysis but many of the best
investments that happened in a
particular window of time or companies
that we had previously met
we'd already made them before we should
have been prepared we should be even
better prepared to make a good decision
now why do we not do that and so we
tried to think about do we ensure that
the people who were there before meet
them again because they have a sense of
continuity and how far they've
progressed but do we also inject some
fresh pair of eyes to help guard against
the individual who maybe is jaded by
their past experience
sometimes we have to switch who the
point person is because some of the
chemistry is just between a founder and
an investor that you know it's a
personal relationship you're joining
somebody's board and so sometimes the
person who met the company and you know
google is a case in point where the
person who found google for sequoia was
doug leone the person who became the
board member was mike moretz
right there was just mike had the right
chemistry with the founders the right
experience because of yahoo and that
made sense for us and so we always try
to think about what's the right match do
we have the right group of people in the
room and at the end of the day back to
the rugby analogy we have to win as a
team
we have to win as a team which is why
things like the midas list are a little
bit insidious from our point of view
culturally because it tries to create
individual attribution
when we have a success at sequoia when
there's a company that goes public or
gets acquired we actually write an email
internally and we enumerate all the
people that contributed to the success
of the company not just the person whose
name is normally attached to it as the
board member
i love that
sebastian maliby
power law or the power law i don't know
if there's a definite article on the
book title
what did he
leave out
what did he
not cover
right what if if he said you know what
roloff i'd love for you to write
an appendix or an afterward or a sidebar
anything at all just to make this more
complete or more
compelling what would you do
maybe because of the time period that it
covers
i think the professionalization of the
industry that's happening right now is
something that's
not fully captured in the book
could you just for people who don't have
a familiarity with with the venture
capital world what would be some of the
components of that professionalization
if you go back 25 years the typical
venture firm had
eight to twelve investors
just factually they were probably white
men at the time that obviously is
changing very quickly in our industry
appropriately
but you had a handful of people sitting
on a table making investments
the total organization size was maybe 25
you know they had some assistance some
receptionist maybe a finance person
maybe they were outsourcing everything
and there was very little offered in the
way of services to portfolio companies
to help them it was just
small professional services
organizations at some level that were
investors and today our team at sequoia
u.s and europe is about 180 and like i
mentioned earlier the investment team is
still pretty small we have 25-ish
investors in our business but
we have marketing capabilities we have
data science we have engineering we have
products
we obviously offer talent services to
our portfolio companies we have a big
finance organization now that you know
manages the complexity of all of this
and so we've just changed as a business
to be able to serve founders you know
the business has gotten more competitive
and so
you can't just be money as you pointed
out earlier there's just so many people
who willing to write checks you know
that is not a differentiator
what is it that i'm offering an
entrepreneur that that makes him or her
choose to work with me because they
think that i have a disproportionate
impact on their chance of success
right and that's partly me my experience
my partners and what we bring as a team
and what are the other services around
our partnership that we can deliver to
help you succeed
completely agree just having watched
from the cheap seats where i can you
know keyboard quarterback
just having observed
i think that would be a really important
addition in your
appendix
epilogue to sebastian maliby's book now
let's say the editor comes back and says
okay
this is great
however we'd love
one example
of
the professionalization
really working if there's kind of a
specific example
and then we'd love for you to include
a counter example
if such exists and the reason i ask i've
been kind of out of this world for a
while but i do remember back in the day
this was probably let's call it 2008
2009
which was a great time i mean i really
lucked lucked out with that time period
so if i started this 10 years later
things would look very different but
i i remember steve anderson of baseline
ventures always
impressing me just because he seemed to
do so much with so little just in terms
of
actual
boots on the ground so if there's sort
of a specific example that you could
give of the professionalization really
working i'd love to to see and by the
way just one or two more questions
i know we've gone pretty long so i
appreciate your time but one example of
it really working and then if there are
any counter examples kind of throwbacks
or
kind of lean and mean
operations that that you admire and
think do a good job
so when i say what i did it doesn't mean
that other models don't work
i think for us it's what works
repeatedly
right right and even in our own business
there are examples where an individual
partner has an idea forms a connection
with a particular team and can bring
that entire opportunity home
and then that partner probably is most
of the interface for that company in
terms of company building board building
and things like that so i mean
and and we want to encourage that and
actually at sequoia one of our cultural
frameworks is maintaining tension
between individualism and teamwork
it's not either or it's and we want both
you need to stick your neck out you need
to do exceptional work you need to be
accountable for what you do but you also
need to be supportive as a team member
because that's that's part of what we've
been able to endure as a partnership
it's both so can you do incredibly well
as an individual or a collection of
individuals absolutely but it's the
cultural consistency for us inside our
organization is we need that
for us to consistently do well
to give you an example i mean we built
internal systems now for us to track
companies so we have you know
if you give me a company name i could
look it up and i can tell you
have we met it who met it what are the
notes
what did they think of the company i
have data sign signals that tell me you
know how this company is doing the
proprietary to give me a sense of
whether or not it's worth pursuing so
these are things that you know didn't
exist in our industry 15 years ago and
jim actually jim gates was one of the
first ones to help us pioneer with us he
built a system
called early bird which is part of how
we identified whatsapp oh wow because
whatsapp was growing outside america
because of the way that cell phone
carriers outside america were charging
people on a per sms basis and in the us
we had all-you-can-eat plans
and so whatsapp was growing our data
science efforts showed it
and no one in america is paying
attention to it because no one in
silicon valley or the us was using
whatsapp and so we connected with jan
he'd worked at yahoo and so we were able
to use our historical yahoo connection
to make sure we can get to him but that
is a glimmer into the sort of data
science capabilities that we've now
honed a decade later that give us an
unfair advantage so that to me is a
concrete example of how business is
better for it it doesn't substitute for
the inside the grit the salesmanship
that individual partner has in actually
landing an entrepreneur
yeah
thank you
i have two more questions second to last
question is
the billboard question which i ask a
fair amount if it's a dead end it's a
dead end sometimes it is and i take the
blame for that but
if you could put a message something on
a billboard that would reach billions
or millions
you pick
of people could be a quote
could be
a question could be an image could be
anything non-commercial
and this is a
metaphor question of course could be a
push message on a phone doesn't really
matter
what might you put on that billboard
since i was aware that this was a
potential question i had some time to
think about it beforehand perfect
so my answer would be dare to dream
and the reason i said that is actually
when i when i interviewed at paypal and
peter interviewed me part of what he
talked about is the
people's failure to understand repeat
games
so if i told you to take a chance on
your career with one roll of the dice
proverbially
pretty dicey to do that pun intended but
if instead i told you look you you have
one shot and if it doesn't work out
there's another one and another one
another one by the way you know you have
many at-bats so to speak there are many
different opportunities for different
companies and over your career would you
take a chance on something that has a
low probability of success and that's
fun along the way yeah sure you would
and so i saw so many of my classmates
i've seen so many people over the years
make safe decisions played safe they
make these conservative decisions oh i
can't take a chance on this thing what
if this company fails and so and they
just end up getting in a rut and then
you know before you know it they're
they're in their 40s they have a midlife
crisis they feel that they've wasted
their lives and so dare to dream take a
chance
just do something interesting
and just think if it doesn't work out
then there's something else there's
something else just keep taking more
chances
i love that and it's good advice for me
right now i have something very absurd
cooking with a very low probability of
success so
i'm gonna take that as an endorsement of
my path
but absolutely i mean
the most boring thing is a life left
unexamined right i mean
yeah
it's fun who cares you've had so much
success i mean and no one remembers you
for your failures by the way yeah can
you enumerate the six companies seven
companies that i invested in that were
complete write-offs probably not but you
remember the ones that made it right
yeah
good point
get over it
get over it and go do it
uh well roloff this has been a lot of
fun i've really enjoyed this
conversation is there anything else that
you would like to
mention anything you'd like to draw
attention to closing comments
or requests of my audience in any
capacity is there anything else you
would like to say and of course people
can find you online on twitter and
instagram roloffbotha on linkedin the
same will include all of these links in
the show notes for people who want to
find those directly in the show notes
but is there anything else that you
would like to add before we come to a
close
i'll just reiterate the date to dream
you know carpe diem seize the day make
the most of the opportunities in front
of you
all right well that's a perfect place
to end and thank you once again for the
time this was really fun really enjoyed
it took a ton of notes
you certainly saw me scribbling people
who watch the video will see me
scribbling lots and lots of notes
and it's given me a lot to think about
which is great i'm i'm
really
excited to pursue this absurd idea that
i have and if it fails nobody will
remember in three years anyway so it's
fine and
for everybody who is interested in
resources everything we've talked about
will be in the show notes links to
everything you can imagine including all
the books and people and so on at
tim.blog podcasts
and until next time
be just a little kinder than necessary
and follow the advice dare to dream get
after it get it done
thanks folks
you